i have a background in like video
production right and editing so i was
like yo this is a good way to just get
my face out there what at least while i
don't have any resources
and um
it turned out like it went viral like
the first one i did it was like it went
more viral than anything i'd ever done
so i was just like [ __ ] why don't i just
keep on shooting on your iphone no i
shoot on the cameras um it's the same
camera camera for the past like four
years it's a panasonic gh5 shout out to
the gh5 gh5 is a hell of a camera
especially get the right lens on that
thing oh yeah shoot any video on that i
put the l series the canon l series on
that joint and we just we just go do you
like um
like outside of the those videos like do
you have a lot like when you even when
you bring in like an outside director do
you still have a lot of say like kind of
in individuals
well since you kind of have background
in that
yeah i've never done i've never had um
outside director you're um
like videographer everything's in-house
everything's in-house but um i plan on
like getting somebody to do my videos at
some point you know do you have like a
guy you use or you just it's all you
it's all me you edit so you edit your
own videos yeah i did my own videos
that's fire thank you bro what all in
the creative process do you handle
yourself
um everywhere like as far as uh i
produce my own stuff um i write
obviously i record myself
uh the only thing i don't do is mix i
like i'm not an engineer i can't i can't
i can mix well enough only so you can
hear it and be like oh this is cool but
like i never like what people here on
the record is not me makes it so you
make the beats you record yourself you
write
you're doing the videos are you doing
the hard work
yeah i do the artwork a lot of times wow
that's pretty big man also it keeps a
lot of money in your pockets yeah but
it's fun for me like i think um i just
like creating stuff so
it's nothing for me to do all this stuff
because i have fun doing it you know
like even when i feel like soon i'm
gonna step away from rap to do some
other cool [ __ ] you know what i mean
it's just like i just want to make cool
[ __ ] like what if let's say you step
away from rap in two years what is what
what do you want to do
uh i want to like see my friends win you
know so it's like i want to build their
careers and it's like because that's how
fun it is for me just to do stuff and to
see it work
so i just uh really want to focus on
supporting the people around me and
seeing what they can do with their you
know with their talents